I am not in favor of Senator Dianne
Feinstein retiring because then what
happens
I can't believe I've seen conservatives
publish columns on this talk onto this
road Diane Feinstein she's almost 90.
she she has been home now she's been
home since February
and I she says it's because she's
recovering from shingles that may or may
not be the case but she's she's pushing
90. she did temporarily at least give up
her seat on the Senate Judiciary
Committee but she remains in the Senate
keep her there forever
[Music]
Dianne Feinstein retires then what then
the Democrats in California appoint a
much younger more energetic more capable
Democrat to take her place no thanks